I do feel like I'm reading a Dr. Seuss book right now.
I'm not going to lie.
Okay.
All right.
I got, I went a little bit far with the, with the, you know, rhyming.
Did you tell it to rhyme with him or did it just do that on its own?
I said, like, what did I say?
Do some catchy names or something like that.
I just started during the countdown.
Yeah.
Smooth.
What do you think of my new, my new light?
It's a.
Oh, dude, I can see.
Okay.
It's like pretty good.
Here I'll show you like the, the difference.
It's like kind of noticeable, uh, but only like if you see like the before and after.
Okay.
So this is like with it on, this is with it off.
Oh, okay.
Nice.
You can see a pretty substantial.
Yeah.
It's pretty good.
And I could like totally.
I don't know.
I feel like I want to, I think I have a little bit more.
I've got a, I've got a ring light right there.
Yeah.
You can kind of see when I block it, but I, I think, you know, I don't think I'm that
much tanner than you.
So I think it's got to be largely the yellow light that's above me as well.
That makes the difference on the video.
It could be, I have like the color temps all like, cause I was having all sorts of weird
like color temp problems with it.
So I think I have it like kind of, kind of okay for now.
God, it worked out nice.
Well, sorry for everybody who's actually listening on an audio medium for this podcast.
If you want to check out the color difference of our skin and Joel's new, uh, light head
over to critical thinking podcast on YouTube.
Um, but with that, uh, let's see what we got for today.
Okay.
So actually I really liked this topic today.
We're talking about, um, hacker brain hacks and essentially how to get over some of the
things that make bug bounty so difficult.
Um, so I think that's going to be really cool topic.
Joel, I'm going to say, check out this document.
And I did my research today and, and I have an outline with beautiful bullet points with
look at these rhyming headers.
This is incredible.
I mean, most of the time, most of the time I'm the one who goes really crazy on the, like
the Google doc side.
So this is, uh, this is nice.
This is cool, man.
Thanks, man.
I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm learning a thing or two.
I'm, I'm flexing my, uh, Google docs muscles a little bit.
Um, but all right, before we get into that content, let's check out some new stuff.
Uh, I'll take the first one.
Um, this is another, uh, we've mentioned this guy on, on the pod before demon dev at D3 mon
dev.
I call, I mentioned, I had to message him afterwards and apologize because I actually called him demand
last time, which is not what it is.
Demon dev.
Um, but, uh, I follow this guy.
He puts out really good stuff.
Um, one of the things that I really liked that he put out recently was, um, this website
called sequence diagram.org, which allows you to really cleanly and easily make these sort
of sequence diagrams, um, where you've got like, uh, several, you know, pieces of, of,
uh, the diagram vertically.
And then you've got lines sort of jumping between each one of them.
It's really helpful for diagramming things like reverse proxies and, uh, POC flows.
So I wanted to shoot it, shout it out on the podcast because I think this could really help
for creating really in-depth POCs and making sure your reports are really understandable.
So we'll drop that link down in the description.
Definitely check it out.
Um, should really help.
Yeah, for sure.
And this is something that I see a lot in like the corporate type of space where like
engineering documents have this, this type of stuff all the time, like just to help you
understand like what's going on, how stuff is supposed to work.
So I think that this is like a great step towards just like making your reports more
readable and making them easier to triage.
And at the end of the day, your reports are going to be read by the enterprise corporate
security people.
So it's exactly what they want to see.
Yeah.
Super awesome.
Cool.
Um, yeah.
So next, next thing, uh, we, we've got, uh, I'll jump, I'll jump one over, but, uh,
Jay Haddix, uh, previous podcast guest, uh, he created this new tool called sub recon GPT.
And, uh, it's, it's, you know, it's an awesome implementation of like, how do we apply AI and
GPT and that kind of stuff into like the bug bounty hacking space.
And so basically what he did is he created a very, very simple Python script that just
takes a list of sub domains as input, and then it feeds them into chat GPT and it asks
for similar sub domains.
And then it'll use that to essentially like generate like a, like a word list, uh, or
something, and then it will try and resolve those domains.
So it's super, super awesome, you know, way of just like kind of manipulating that data.
I think it's really tricky to do this type of stuff without some sort of like manual intervention
and like coming up with like variation word lists and all that kind of stuff is really,
really awesome for finding like, um, super niche assets.
Um, I, I, I don't know if he wants to be shout out for this, but, uh, a mutual friend of
ours who, uh, used to work with Zayat.
That's what I'll say.
I think, you know, I'm talking about.
Oh, we'll believe it.
Yeah.
So, so, so.
It's like a recon God.
Okay.
And the way that he does this is by generating super bespoke custom word lists for all of the
targets that he hacks on.
He'll like, he has this whole custom flow that he does where he takes like data and he'll use
it to generate all these like custom word lists.
And then he uses it to like brute force either sub domains or end points or whatever.
And he finds like the craziest stuff by doing this.
Yeah.
It's really gnarly when you've got stuff like that.
I remember I did, I went that far once.
I've done it a couple of times, but it really paid off once at a live hacking event for PayPal.
And I found this application that was old and everyone had forgotten about it.
And I had to like go through the, you know, all these, you know, hoops to get, even get
access to it.
But once I did, it was a vuln all over the place, right?
It was just vulns everywhere.
And I was like, man, this thing is a cash cow.
I need to like milk this for all it's worth.
Yeah.
And so I got ahold of the documentation for it.
And I was trying to enumerate all of these endpoints that they were talking about in the
documentation that I couldn't find, right?
The functionality.
And so I couldn't find it.
So what I ended up doing was just parsing, you know, there's like some really old school
tool.
I can't remember the name of it, but essentially it goes out to the website, scrapes the, you
know, the words used and then uses that to, you know, do some brute forcing.
And I did that and I, you know, outlined the common structures of the URLs and I brute forced
and I got so many hits and it probably resulted in over 50K of bounties from that one.
Wow, dude.
And so, yeah, it's, it's, it's crazy what, what you can do when you really take this extra
level and go a little bit deeper.
I think this is a great tool that does it.
Also, I'm a little salty because this has been on my videos for a really long time.
And if I wasn't in the middle of a reno right now, then I would absolutely.
I would absolutely be, have had this done.
Yeah.
Anyway, it's less than a hundred lines of Python.
It's super awesome.
Yeah.
I think you probably could have even had chat GPT write this itself to be, to be honest.
It's like 50 lines.
Yeah.
This, this is, it kind of reminds me of the asset note wordless, but like one step further
because asset note wordless are pulled from big queries.
So they're, they're more like, you know, modern, so to speak, right?
They're more like up to date with like what's going on right now.
Like they're based off of analytics and like query data from like real requests over like
a recent time span versus, you know, just some wordless is commonly used stuff, but not
necessarily accurate to the current like date.
And this is like, you know, that kind of like bespokeness, the like recency that's like
very like targeted one step further.
So I think it's really awesome.
And I'm probably going to be throwing this in my flow.
I mean, he, he says, he says for sure, this is very beta, you know, here.
So, and if you look at the code, it's pretty much asking chat GPT.
It's like generate five subdomains similar to XYZ.
I don't even think, yeah, it's not, it's not using lane chain or anything like that.
It's just using the open AI, Python API.
So there's definitely rooms for improvement here.
If anybody wanted to go and do like a pull request on this, I'm sure Jason would be thrilled.
Yeah.
Yeah, for sure.
All right.
Nice.
So next thing that I wanted to talk about was we love to keep Kaido in the loop.
We love to talk about Kaido.
I think it's a great tool.
It's the primary tool I'm using right now for web proxying.
Um, and, uh, love to see something like this.
The cyber mentor actually put out a video recently, uh, entitled this new web hacking tool may replace burp suite.
And I was like, oh yeah, here we go.
And he does a, um, quite a long walkthrough of, of what it, what it looks like, you know, to use Kaido, uh, use it up against a target.
Um, so I was really thrilled to see that.
It's like an 11 minute video.
Um, I think, I think Kaido is gaining more and more traction.
And, uh, it's something that you might want to go and subscribe to right now, uh, and get the pro access because it's only like, I want to say it's only like $10 a month.
It's either $10 a month or a hundred dollars a year, depending on how you want to pay for it.
And, uh, yeah, I mean, I'm just going to, I'm just going to read some facts, okay?
Who knows?
Portsmigger currently costs, I think $500 a year.
Yeah.
It's ridiculous.
So, if it's a cost thing for you, you know, there's the, there's the numbers.
Yeah, for sure.
And, um, and you also have an, an ability right now to influence the, the, um, building of this product.
You can submit issues, you can talk to the team.
So definitely don't miss out on that.
Yeah, for sure.
It's not like there aren't features that like, like I use both a lot now and it's like, I'll definitely be using Kaido and I'll be like, ah, I wish there was this feature from Burp.
Like it'll be just like little, like, you know, quality of life things, but like those little things, like they add up over time and they're just like little features that Burp has just had more time to add in.
But there's also those same things in Kaido, right?
And so like, for example, I, every time I have to go back in Burp and I, and I intercept a request and I have to click forward, forward, forward, forward, forward, forward, forward, instead of just going directly to the request and then hitting forward.
I'm like, oh, I hate this, you know, and, and Kaido, it just, it queues up all the requests.
You can just click the request.
You want to forward and just boom, forward.
And it's like, uh, amazing.
And, uh, and, you know, switching projects is so much easier in Kaido.
I can do hacking from my Chromebook on Kaido.
You know, while I'm sitting in my living room.
So there's, there's a lot of really great stuff to set up there.
Yeah.
And if you see those features that aren't there, just shoot a message to the dev team and they're, they're like super responsive.
They hop on stuff right away.
So yeah, it's, it's really awesome.
I actually have a little thing set up with them now where I just like dropped them a loom video.
So I don't even really have to do much else.
I just like, you get the private line, outputs a URL.
I'm just like, boom, and I don't even say anything.
I just send them the loom video and it gets like put into an issue.
And it makes its way into the next dev cycle.
So that's what the enterprise plan is.
Oh, okay.
You know, let's just say, I got the inside scoop.
Yeah, I got the custom support.
Wow.
Oh my gosh.
Um, okay.
So actually, so two more things.
I'm sorry, Joel.
I actually didn't put it on the doc.
Um, well, the, the one thing that I wanted to talk about was, I just wanted to give a shout
out to Yobert, um, hacker one, co-founder.
He has been pumping out him and the hacker one dev team.
I will, I will include them all in that.
I've been pumping out some crazy features lately.
And one, I just want to say, I have hacked with Yobert before.
Phenomenal hacker, very skilled.
And, you know, the guy's probably loaded at this point, you know, having been a hacker
one, co-founder and hacker one doing the way that it is.
And he's still in there every day running the engineering team with, with hacker one.
So mad respect there.
Um, but two, man, have there been some nice features getting pushed out lately?
Um, they just released a command palette for, for hacker one, which allows you to really
quickly navigate around and, you know, submit new reports really easy, open policy pages
really easily.
That's amazing.
Um, there's some encoding tools, some new analytics, and it's just, it's wonderful.
So, um, if you haven't checked out your hacker one dashboard recently, or if you're not seeing
these tweets from Yobert about, um, you know, the new features that are going out, definitely
give him a follow on Twitter.
Um, and just to be, just to be clear, it's J O B R T.
Yes.
Joe bird.
Yo bird.
Uh, yeah.
If you're looking it up afterwards, we'll, we'll link it in the, we'll link it.
Cool.
Um, yeah.
So this, uh, this, this person, uh, Justin L's L Z E L Z E. Um, he, uh, he tweeted out
this awesome.
I, I don't know if he wrote this blog or, or what?
No, I don't think so.
I'm not sure.
He, I think he's just linking to a cloud cloud flare or actually, this is actually not even
cloud flare.
This is something.
Yeah.
It's on, uh, iq.thc.org.
Um, and just as the author is root.
So I, my, my assumption, this is just like somebody who's like a self-hosted blog.
So I'm not really sure who wrote this.
Yeah.
Right.
However, that's where the best content is.
Yeah.
It doesn't really, it doesn't really matter.
However, it does talk about this really cool thing.
I never heard of this.
I've heard of very similar things, um, but it's called cloud flare D tunnels or cloud
flare D tunnels.
I'm not really sure, uh, which one it is, but, uh, essentially if you're familiar with
Ngrok, uh, N-G-R-O-K, it's kind of like a tunnel service that gives you a public
endpoint, uh, and you can tunnel it to basically any like TCP port on your local host.
Um, and that's really awesome for a lot of different things.
It's awesome from like a developer perspective, if you're doing testing, but it's also really
awesome from a hacker perspective where you can host your POCs without having to host
your POCs.
Yeah, you can absolutely do that.
And the, one of the reasons why I wanted to add this to the list for today was, um, this,
I think there's also some really nice, um, functionality here.
And I'm realizing now that, you know, cloud flare may have some terms of services against
this, so, you know, read the, read the docs before you do this.
But I was thinking this would be amazing for, um, you know, hosting your, your payloads,
uh, for hosting your, your action.
And this is less than a bug bounty context, but more in just an actual like internal assessment
or, you know, red team perspective where you're actually trying to hack into an organization.
And we all know that probably easiest way is going to be to do social engineering or some
sort of like something like that.
Right.
So, um, this sort of thing is really great because a lot of times your domains get burned
and stuff like that.
Uh, or like you've got some, uh, uh, next gen firewall that's blocking, you know, domains
that don't have a certain accreditation score or whatever.
So, um, it's really helpful to host your, your C2 or anything like that behind, uh, an accredited
domain like cloud flare.
So, um, this is just a shout out for any of you that are actually actively doing red team
stuff.
This might be something you can utilize in your, in pivoting or in your, your day-to-day
assessments.
Yeah.
I also really liked that, uh, this, this blog talks about that you can do like SSH and stuff
over this, which is, it's just a really interesting, um, use case.
I'm not sure if this adds any sort of like implicit security on top of what you're doing.
I'm not sure like what kind of access controls or whatever you might be able to, to perform
on this, but, um, that's a really interesting use case.
I'm not sure if you could do that with Angrock.
So it seems like it's just a raw TTCP.
Yeah.
So, so pretty, pretty interesting stuff.
Um, definitely useful.
And I think I'm going to put this in my bookmarks for, uh, for payloads and stuff.
Oh no, they, they do have, they do have secure.
Yeah.
They, they have TLS.
Cool.
Nice.
Okay.
So that's it for the news section onto the meat, onto the meat and potatoes.
So, um, yeah, I guess I'll, I'll preface this by saying I'm a full-time bug bounty hunter.
And, um, I guess being a full-time bug bounty hunter, you have a lot more, I guess, mental
challenges with bug bounty.
You're, you have different mental challenges.
Let me, let me just put that there.
Um, because one, it's your, it's your livelihood and you're doing it every day and it becomes
your job.
Um, but, uh, you know, on the other hand, you're also not having to juggle bug bounty in your,
in your full-time job and that sort of thing.
So at some point I want to, I want to do, and I've, I've got a little section at the end of
this doc.
I'm not sure if we'll get to it today about just some of the tips that I've learned from
doing bug bounty full-time.
And I know we talked about it a little bit on the full-time bug bounty episode, but I've
got some other, other stuff as well that we'll get to.
But the main, the main focus for today was like mentality stuff.
Um, so I broke it down into three sections.
You can see them in the doc, Joel, before hacking, during hacking and after hacking.
Okay.
And these are the kind of, I just kind of brainstormed for a little while.
And then I used, you know, chat GVT to come up with some snazzy names for each section,
um, about what kind of struggles you might be running into at each one of these phases,
um, on your hacking journey.
I do feel like I'm reading a Dr. Seuss book right now.
I'm not going to lie.
Okay.
All right.
I got, I went a little bit far with the, with the, uh, you know, rhyming.
Did you tell it to rhyme, or did it just do that on its own?
I said, like, what did I say?
Do some catchy names or something like that for X, Y, Z.
So, uh, I don't know.
We'll, we'll, we'll see what we got.
Okay.
First one, um, this is in the before hacking section.
Um, I see this one all the time and I've, uh, me, AKA chat GVT, AKA Dr. Seuss, uh, has
named this one procrastination education.
Okay.
So essentially the topic behind this is like, you are scared to start hacking because you
think you're going to fail.
So you just educate, educate, educate, educate, educate, educate as a form of procrastination
against, you know, doing actual hacking.
See this all the time.
Some people affectionately call it tutorial hell, um, or not affectionately call it tutorial
hell.
Um, but this is definitely a pitfall and definitely something that, that, yeah, a lot of people
run into.
What do you think about that?
Yeah.
Um, I think we've touched on this a couple of different times.
Um, it's really, really challenging because when you're new to this, you're like, what,
what do I even start?
What do I look at?
Like, what do I need to know?
Right.
And that's a, those are like completely valid questions and ones that you need to answer.
But the question is like, how much do you need to answer it?
Right.
Like, do you need to fully understand every aspect of the OWASP top 10 or every, like
every conceptual part of like a CSRF, or do you just need to know like what it looks like
and how to exploit it?
Right.
And I think there's a fine line between like how far you need to deep dive on learning a
topic versus how far you need to deep dive just to exploit it.
And, um, I think this happens a lot, especially with new people where they just want to like
absorb knowledge and keep learning and keep learning.
And that's great.
But like, when you're going to start hacking, like you gotta, you gotta branch at some point
and, and start, you can keep learning, but like, you gotta start hacking and putting that
knowledge to use because that's, what's really going to solidify it in your brain.
Yeah, I totally agree.
And I think what, one of the things I've told people is like, Hey, um, you know, do your
basic introductions into how websites work.
You know, I, I have this flow that I go, go through with, with the people that I'm
teaching, which disclaimer is not anyone that's ever messaged me online.
I cannot take remote mentorships.
Please stop messaging me about that.
Um, I really appreciate you reaching out, but like, I only mentor people that I know in
real life.
Uh, and so sorry about that.
Disclaimer.
I'm the same way, by the way, like it's nothing personal.
It's just like, it's a, it's a large time commitment.
And like, we want to set expectations accordingly.
We don't want to like set, set you up for failure or set you up to expect something that's
not going to happen.
So we just kind of have signed it off entirely.
And we basically only do mentorships on like very rare one-off cases.
And it's usually people that we know.
Yeah.
So, so feel free to shoot me a message.
If you have a question, a pointed question or something like that, I'll definitely get
to it, but I can't just do a formal mentorship with everyone.
Okay.
So what I was going to say though, was when I am mentoring people, I always walk them through
this flow of like, okay, um, you know, first we got to understand how a website works and
how, you know, HTTP works and how DNS works.
And we walk through all that whole flow of what happens when you put a, you know, a URL
in your browser.
And then they understand that.
And they understand how to view it in burp.
They understand how to, um, you know, modify, uh, parameters.
You know, they understand how to use an HTTP proxy.
Um, and then, you know, I have them start working on, uh, uh, Portswigger WSA.
Um, and, and once they kind of get through that, I say a little bit into that, you know, once
they've gone through the access control section or the broken, uh, or the business logic section,
I say, okay, now we need to start pivoting part of your time from, from a very, very, very
early stage into actual hacking.
So take 10% of your time, do hacking.
Take 20% of your time, do hacking all the way up to 50, 60, 70% of your time doing hacking.
And it's going to feel like crap in the beginning.
Cause you're not going to know what you're doing.
And you're going to be looking at requests that don't make any sense.
Uh, but just being in the HTTP requests, reading the headers, reading the body, being
curious, understanding how functionality in the UI maps to API requests in the backend.
That is the meat.
You need to be so comfortable with that before you can effectively do hacking.
Um, and the more time you spend that's, that's all, you know, that's all more experience that
you've got.
And, and, uh, that will serve you every single one.
Even if you don't find anything, if you don't understand anything that will serve you in
becoming a better hacker, uh, periodically as, as you continue to gradually, as you continue
to grow.
So don't neglect that time or else you'll never get anywhere and you'll be stuck in tutorial
hell.
Yeah.
A hundred percent.
Like did that just like asking like, why does this work or how does this work?
Or like, where does this value come from is super instrumental to like understanding the
core deep functionality of how an application is, is functioning and where data is going and
all that kind of stuff.
Um, cool.
Yeah.
So, so you got to start hacking, right?
But here, this is like the next thing that I see, like second most common thing for new
hackers, analysis paralysis.
It's like, what program do I pick?
What do I hack on?
What do I focus on?
Like, oh man, this is, this is like such a common thing.
We talked a little bit about this during the, how to pick a good program.
Um, but I think especially when you're new and you're trying to pick, pick, pick like the
first program to hack on, just pick like whatever sounds interesting.
Right.
Um, I, I think it's almost more important not to really focus on bounties.
Bounties are very alluring.
It's very like tempting to like want the like big high cash money.
Prizes and stuff.
And I'm not saying that it's impossible to get those on larger programs that typically
have the higher bounty tables, but it's going to be more challenging because there's a lot
more people who have come before you, who have looked at that stuff a lot more than you
have, and they have that leg up and you can get there for sure, but it's going to take
more time and you may not get the sort of instant gratification or, um, satisfaction
that you're looking for on one of those larger programs.
So I recommend just picking whatever sounds interesting because that's going to help you
with the natural drive for hacking.
Pick a website that you're familiar with or like a tool that you've heard of or something
that would be like, like for some people it's, oh, I want to hack the government.
Okay.
So focus on a DOD program.
Don't worry about bounties.
They have a huge program, huge scope, just like hack some DOD stuff.
Then you can be like, yeah, I hacked the government, you know, cool.
Whatever you want, like for bragging rights, you know, or like, you know, whatever service
you want to, you want to hack like that, that's what I would recommend.
I, I, I sort of agree with that, Joel.
I think the DOD is a little bit of an exception.
I do mention the DOD as well to most people, just because it does give you some sort of payment.
You know, you're, you get to say, Hey, you know, I hacked the DOD and that feels cool.
And that's nice.
I normally recommend people to start from the beginning with bounty programs because, and skip
the, the VDP stage because it feels so much better to get an actual bounty.
Yeah.
Right.
And, and some people, some people will say, Hey, I just want a valid bug and you know what?
That's fine.
Maybe VDPs are for you then.
But my suggestion is to actually go and get an actual bounty.
Um, and if it takes extra time, great.
But here's the problem with the, with, with the VDP programs.
One, nobody looks at them.
And so, uh, you know, you can go on there and you may be able to find some bones, but you're
not going to get a good, um, indicator of how deep you need to go to find bugs on an actual
bug bounty program.
Um, yeah.
And two, obviously you're, you're not getting paid for your time, which is, it's not going
to help you with some of the other stuff we'll talk about a little bit later, which is, uh,
bug bounty being a results, um, results for money based system.
Right.
It's a, it's, it's, some would call it a merit, meritocracy, but I'll, I'll say it.
It's a, it's, it's a results for money based system.
So if you spend a bunch of time, you don't get the results, you don't get any money.
Right.
Um, and so I think that's something that kind of takes some time to get used to and something
that you can, um, you know, sort of edge into from the beginning.
Um, I will say from before Joel, uh, that was episode 13, how to pick a good bug bounty
program.
We probably shouldn't spend too much more time, uh, too much time on how to actually,
you know, pick a program on here.
I will say one tip from that episode, go, go watch the whole episode and understand it.
But one tip that I'll pull away from that is if you can hack a website that you use.
Yeah.
And, and I'll clarify, I don't know if I'm, I may have missbooking.
I'm not really advocating that you pick VDPs over bug bounty programs.
I think I would always try and pick a bug bounty program, except in, you know, like we talked
about, like maybe the edge case for the DoD.
But what I want to say is don't focus on how high the bounties are.
Right.
So if it's like 1k crits versus 3k crits versus 5k crits.
Yeah.
We all want a 5k crit, but a bounty is a bounty.
And it's really just like, what interests you?
If the thing, if the thing you want to hack has a 1k bounty, that's fine.
Like I would, I would push towards that.
And then like, once, once you feel more confident, then like go hack whatever and, and don't care
so much about what the target is.
But for that initial drive, it's really, it's really important to like, you know, want to
hack what you're hacking.
Yeah.
Totally agree, man.
Okay.
Next one is, um, automation obsession.
And now I'm feeling silly about all these.
Automation, automation obsession is the next one.
Very aptly named because, um, this is actually a pitfall that I fell into.
Um, and I got very fortunate, um, and I, that I actually got a crazy automation bug, uh, which
got me started.
My first bug was a 4k subdomain takeover, which is high even by today's standards.
Um, but, uh, what I wanted to say on this one was a lot of people will feel like they need to
build out their whole recon automation system and do all this programming.
And a lot of these people are programmers, by the way.
So it makes sense that you want to do the thing that you, you know, already know how to do.
I would say, do not do that if you, if you really want to get good at this, because, um, you know, automation
is a great, is a great field.
And it's something that you can absolutely make a lot of bounties off of.
Um, but first you need to know how to hack.
And for this, I will go ahead and refer you all.
And we're going to talk about this a little bit more, um, in the recon section.
But the point of this automation is to find volumes, right?
And you're not going to know how to find volumes until you actually find vulnerabilities.
So, so I would recommend putting the automation aside, even if it's small automation, like, oh,
I want to be able to take this thing from gal and put it into something else, which is a part of normal hacking.
Um, I would say, hold off on that as much as you can.
And when you're hacking hack and when you're automating automate, but try not to mix the
two too much.
Yeah.
Cool.
So for the next one, I wish this one rhymed and was more fun to talk about, but imposter
syndrome, it's, uh, it's just, that's just, uh, you know, that's not an easy one to swallow.
Um, I'm just going to say that, uh, it doesn't, it doesn't go away.
It gets easier to deal with, uh, because you can understand it and spot it much easier,
um, as you deal with it more, but it's kind of one of those things that's always going to
be there and you just have to figure out the right ways to like, stop thinking about it
or stop like, you know, just like thinking and thinking and thinking and, and, and, you
know, mulling it over in your brain and just like, Oh, I'm not good enough.
Oh, like, Oh, this FOMO and whatever.
It's like, just, you know, go back to, to like the early beginner tips, right?
Like procrastination, education, analysis, paralysis.
Okay.
Stop thinking about it.
Stop trying to learn so much.
Just do it.
Right.
Yeah.
And the imposter syndrome thing I think as well is like, it's something that it's something
that you fight with while you're hacking, but it's also something that you fight with
before you're hacking.
And that's why I have it in the, before you're hacking section here, before you're
hacking, if it's preventing you from hacking, I'm not good enough to do that.
You need to punch that in the face.
You need to get upset about, at, at that imposter syndrome and say, listen, that's wrong.
Uh, hacking is not a, a you're good enough or you're not good enough sort of thing.
It's a, it's a process.
And, and I, I'm saying this from being, you know, having done this a lot, guys, this is
not some wishy-washy, you know, you can do it, go get it.
Tony Robbins BS.
Right.
It, this is, this is actually a fact, you know, spending time, uh, in the application,
learning the application is a pivotal part of this.
So even if you don't feel like you're good enough yet, get in there, start learning,
get your hands on it.
Yeah.
And it's not like that meritocracy, like where people think like, oh, the more time I
spend, like, I'm, I'm for sure going to find something like there are going to be times
where you're going to spend a ton of, a ton of time and effort looking for something and
you're not going to find something and you're going to feel extremely like beat up and worn
down.
And you just have to remember like, that's normal.
Okay.
You didn't do anything wrong.
Like that is literally just part of the process.
And you have to realize that you're, you're hunting for gold in a, in a river, you know,
you're, you're like, it's like the 1850s.
It's the gold rush needle in a, like, yeah, needle in a haystack.
And there's no guarantee the needles there, you know, like there's five haystacks, which
one is the needle and start looking a very valuable needle in a golden needle.
Like, yeah, no, no golden needle in the haystack river and the haystack.
Yeah.
Somewhere there's an analogy in there somewhere.
Something like that.
But yes, like, just remember, like, none of this is guaranteed.
Like, we hope to find bad vulnerabilities so that we get paid out, but none of it is ever
like for sure.
And so if you don't find anything, that's kind of a good thing, right?
Like that's, that's kind of, that's kind of a good thing.
Yeah.
And I want to say this as well.
There are a lot of, of people that for most of you, let me just say, there are a lot of
people that are a lot less skilled than you that are getting pounties right now.
I can, I can promise you that.
So get out there and do it.
Okay.
Next one for the before hacking section was motivation deprivation.
Yeah.
Um, and, um, this is, this is a sort of a, a, this is sort of an, a situation that kind
of comes into play when, after you found the dupe, after you haven't been finding anything
for a while and you're starting up hacking again, it can be really challenging to like
take on the huge task of looking at a big application and that sort of thing.
Um, and what I would encourage you all on this one is to just stay, stay curious.
Okay.
Stay, be in it.
Don't be focused too much on the bounties.
Don't be focused too much on, on the finding something, be focused on becoming an expert
on this specific application.
Um, one of the live hacking events that I, that I participated in a while back, I spent
so much time on this one application, two weeks, every day in the JS files, finding everything
I possibly could.
And when I got to that live hacking event, I was like, you know what?
I bet I know everything about this application.
I bet no one here knows more about this application than I do.
So I was, I put a message out in the chat.
I was like, Hey, anybody want to teach me something that I don't know about this application?
Right.
And I got taken to school that day.
Like, like it, but it's that, that sort of confidence is the confidence that you need.
Like by the time that, that live hacking event day came around, I felt like I knew everything
about that application.
But the cool, the part about it is you never will know everything about the application.
And so you can keep on, so I had probably pushed through two or three layers at that point
of, yeah, I think I found everything on this.
Right.
And I, I said, well, let me do another double check.
Let me do another double check.
And then I got to this point and I was, and then I still got taken to school by some of
the other people that are at the live hacking event.
So there's always going to be more to find, um, yeah, dive in.
Yeah.
Super amazing.
And I think you don't have to like, don't, don't take away from that, that you have to be at
a live hacking event to have that kind of moment.
Just like, ask yourself, like when you feel like you're at the edge of knowledge, be like,
is there anything else that I don't know about, or I haven't fully explored?
And that's where your note taking and all that kind of stuff will really come into play.
Dude, I actually want to share this really cool tidbit.
I mentioned a guy a while back, I shouted, shouted them out, um, that I said, Hey, you
know, write down all your attack vectors and go.
And he messaged me the other day because he said, I think I found everything.
Um, and I was like, okay, do it again.
And he's like, okay, I trust you, man.
He found four more bugs.
One of them, which was exactly.
And I was like, dude, you rock way to continue persevering.
And not only that, he had it written down.
It was there, it was right in front of him.
He did, man.
So cool.
Um, okay.
One more thing I wanted to talk about on this.
This is a little bit of live hacking event hack, um, that Mariah and I, uh, put together.
For those of you that don't know, Mariah is my wife.
Um, and so when I, we were going into live hacking events, um, I guess sometimes it's, it's
easy to get overwhelmed.
It's easy to not feel motivated, especially when you're on the live hacking event circuit and
you're doing them every month or every other month, it can get kind of intense.
And so, um, one of the things Mariah came up with was this goal system for me.
So we would say, okay, Justin, um, you know, here are the tiers.
Okay.
At this tier, uh, you know, you can do X, Y, Z.
So like, for example, one of, one of my tiers, uh, for the Vegas, how I've had him in last
year was to get a hot tub.
So if I earn more than X amount, boom, hot tub.
If I earn more than Y amount, boom, cruise, you know?
Um, and so like setting tiers and goals for yourself can be really motivating.
And if you, you can see that sort of prize in the distance, it's easier to stay on top
of it and remember what you're hacking for.
So that's a nice little hack.
Um, you know, define a couple of weeks sprints.
If you're not doing a live hacking event, say, all right, I'm going to hack for the next
three weeks.
If at the end of this three weeks, I've submitted bugs that, uh, you know, sum up to X thousand
dollars, then I'm going to go out to a nice dinner or something like that.
I think that can be really, yeah, for sure.
I was going to go into goals and stuff, but I think it's, we're, we're going to talk about
it a little bit more in the during hacking session.
So, so let's dive into that.
Yeah.
Um, so yeah, during hacking, um, so like the first one, automation obsession.
Now this is like a recurring theme and I'll go, yeah, go ahead.
I copy, I copied that one in there.
I copied that one in there from the other one, just to, just to throw a curve ball at you,
Joel, um, I copied that one in from the before session as well.
And here's why this should, this one should be pretty quick.
I often found when I was trying to shift away from automation obsession that I was, uh, I
would get into hacking.
I'd be like, all right, yeah, cool.
I'm doing this hacking thing.
Right.
And then, and then I like find something interesting and I'm like, oh man, I need to like, I need
to scan for this, you know, or I need to like, be able to, um, evaluate for this vulnerability
very, very quickly.
And so then I would stop what I was doing instead of staying in my zone, in my mode hacking, I
would, you know, fire up Python and start trying to automate that.
And that's an obsession with automation.
Um, don't do that.
When you're hacking hack, when you're automating automate, um, take notes, you know, on what
things you want to automate, come back to it later, but stay in the zone.
Um, because when, when you're in the zone, when you have the application context in your
brain, you need to minimize distractions.
Um, and so automation can be one of those distractions.
Yeah, for sure.
Notes, notes, notes, notes, write everything down.
Come back to it later.
Yeah.
Cool.
Um, recon, cognizance, reconnaissance, cognizance.
That's a, it's a mouthful.
There you go.
Yeah.
Um, so basically just like, there's nothing that really rhymes well with recon.
Reconnaissance, recon, shmeekon.
I don't know.
Yeah.
I don't, yeah.
But it's not like that.
Yeah.
So, so recon.
Reconnaissance, cognizance.
Yeah.
So like, how do you, how do you like get your brain around recon in like a meaningful way?
Right.
I think, um, it's a really easy trap to fall into this like recon hole because for one,
there are so many tools that are just re like literally just for recon subdomain, brute
forcing, uh, path traversal, uh, path, brute forcing, host, brute forcing, uh, fuzz errors,
you know, everything like scanners.
Yeah.
It's all like, you know, it's a bunch of brute forces and that's cool and stuff, but
like, I think it's really easy to fall down a rabbit hole where you, you're like, I don't
get it.
I ran all seven tools that I have and I haven't found a bug yet.
What's going on?
I guess I'm just going to go to the next target.
Right.
And like, there are a lot of hackers who do that, which should tell you that if you don't
do that, you're going to find the stuff that they missed.
So I think recon is really good for identifying attack surface and like seeing what things might
be interesting to poke at or, or maybe taking some notes and, and, and checking those things
out later.
But once you have like, you know, 10 things or whatever, not even like, you know, once you
have a couple of things, just start looking into them and you're going to find other stuff
as you look, because the recon isn't really like the end all be all.
Some bugs do end there, but, but the majority I say don't.
Yeah.
And, and I just love this quote and we clipped it and we put it at the beginning of episode
12 with Jay Haddix, probably one of the most valuable takeaways that he, he, he, we have
from that episode from the recon God himself, Jay Haddix.
He says, I make all these talks about recon to help you find more apps to hack, right?
That's the goal.
So do your recon until you've found an interesting app to hack and then just hack that app instead
of doing recon eternally.
That's, that's my take.
There are some people that have different takes and there are people that subscribe to a lot
more recon heavy methodology.
But at the end of the day, even people like Noggle, right?
You know, he's a big recon guy, but when it comes to the life hacking events, the way
he kills it, the way he ranks top is he gets his head on straight and he focuses and he hacks
the main app.
Yep.
Dives deep.
Yeah.
Very important.
Cool.
Let's talk about goals a little bit, shall we?
Okay.
So let me, let me, let me just say this one.
It says bad rabbit holes, rip your goals.
Wait, did chat GPT come up with that?
No, this one was me.
I'm not going to, I can't even play this one on chat GPT.
This one's for me, bad rabbit holes, rip your goals.
So let me, let me just explain this one.
A while ago on the pod, I, I think we were talking about a treat from Rezo and I had said,
I actually think it's good to rabbit hole and I do still hold that, but I do want to mention
that I think there's a little bit more nuance to the topic and I would love to have Rezo on
sometimes to debate it, but, um, essentially my current place is that you have to be able to
identify what these bad rabbit holes are.
Um, and, um, I've got a couple of little notes here and I'd, I'd be interested in hearing your,
your thoughts as well, Joel, but essentially some ways to identify bad rabbit holes are the
following.
One, it does not expand your scope.
So if this rabbit hole that you're going down doesn't give you access to more scope, you know,
maybe you're trying to figure out a way to access a specific application by like getting
an account there, registering an account or something like that, that might be a good rabbit
hole.
Um, uh, but you know, if you're doing something that doesn't really expand your scope and doesn't
meet any of the following conditions, then it might not be a good rabbit hole.
The next one is low impact.
It doesn't, it doesn't mesh with the application's threat model.
You need to understand what kind of things the application finds valuable and what will
happen at the end of the rabbit hole.
It needs to be a destination rabbit hole.
It needs to be one of those holes that goes down and then you pop off on the other side.
You know, it can't be one that just goes straight down and then you die at the bottom
of the hole.
Okay.
So you need to have a goal with where your rabbit hole should lead you.
Um, and, uh, if you can't clearly see that it's a very big risk to go down that rabbit
hole.
Yeah.
The next one was, um, non-deterministic.
If you think that there is a, if you don't know, I guess this is kind of similar to the
low impact one, but if you don't have a good idea of whether this is going to work out or
not, or you don't see a clear path to whether it's going to work out or not, then this may
be a tricky rabbit hole, right?
Um, if you, if you have a very clear condition, like, oh, I just need to bypass this one piece
and then I've got like an SSRF or this one piece.
And then I've got, you know, an ATO, then that, that could be a good example.
But if it, if it's like, uh, you know, I think once I bypass this one piece, then there could
be like, maybe there's other controls in place, but very likely, you know, if you, if you, you
know, hear yourself having that little internal conversation, then could be a bad rabbit hole.
Um, you have any other thoughts on bad rabbit holes ripping your goals?
Yeah.
So I think, um, I agree with both of you.
Like rabbit holes are both useful and not useful.
Um, and like you said, there are, there are key things that can really help you identify
whether or not you're going down a bad rabbit hole, so to speak.
Um, I think it's really easy to like be able to see it from both sides.
So if you're like, for example, um, something that catches me a lot is account creation, uh,
proxying or something.
If I'm proxying a mobile app, I might be able to proxy the whole app, except for like just
the beginning request or something, or like the, the, the account creation request.
And while that is a really useful attack scenario, it's also only one piece of like the whole
application.
It's only one piece of the flow.
So instead of like rabbit holing down and like spending three hours trying to figure
out why I can't proxy this one request, just write it down, move on, right.
Come back to it later.
And that, that's a great, that's a great point because that does expand your scope a little
bit, right?
That expands your scope to account creation, but it doesn't vastly expand your scope.
Right.
And so it's, it's a very limited, limited scope expansion could be a bad rabbit hole.
And not only that, you might be restricted by like, oh, it's a one-time thing.
Like depending on what the vuln is, you have to think about like what might be the worst
case scenario.
Like if I can imagine of just like being able to get access to this scope and if it's not
like the worst possible thing or worse than other things you could think of, again, just
write it down, like come back to it later because you're spending a lot of that valuable
time, just like trying to debug something when you could be spending that, like doing hacking
and expanding your scope and like learning about the application, all that kind of stuff.
Totally agree on this.
Just want to provide a disclaimer.
I'm pretty sure this is what Rezo was saying from the beginning anyway.
So shout out to him.
Maybe I don't agree with you at all.
I don't know.
Yeah.
I did agree with what you said.
You know, I'm pretty sure this is what Rezo was talking about from the beginning anyway,
but you know, just throwing that out there.
I think there are good rabbit holes and I think there are bad rabbit holes.
And these are some descriptors of a bad rabbit hole.
Yeah.
Hopefully that'll be helpful.
And I will say, I have this one little note before I move on.
You got to trust your intuition on some of these things too.
And this is not as much for you newer hackers, but for you more experienced hackers, let's
say maybe you've looked at 30 to 50 plus applications.
Trust your intuition though, because sometimes your brain knows something that you don't know.
And if you think, man, I just really can't get this one piece of the application out of
my mind, take the hour and just dive in and get a little deeper because I actually have
found some cool stuff by doing that.
And this goes back to the curiosity thing as well.
Sometimes you just want to do cool shit.
And, you know, even if that doesn't end up with a vuln, if you understand how the specific
process works and that makes, that feels good, that feels cool to you, definitely go after.
Before we move on to the next thing, I did want to talk about goals really quick because
this is talked about like talking about like ripped to your goals and stuff, but, but goals
are like really, really important in my opinion about like for, for, for hacking.
Right.
I think, I think one of the most important things you can do when you're hacking at target is
set, set a specific goal.
Okay.
I want to become a super admin.
I want to take over this account.
I want to, uh, get an XSS, uh, whatever it is, right?
Like I just said, this is just wrote, set your goal poles.
Okay.
Well, that's what we're calling you to workshop that one.
No, it's great.
It's great.
Set your goal poles.
Yeah.
So yeah, just set goals.
I think goals are really important.
Um, even if it may seem unattainable in the beginning, having some sort of frame of reference,
just like how with earnings, you have goals, just so you have something to look towards
something to like picture and think about goals when hacking are really important as well,
because it's going to help you frame your entire reference about the application.
What could I do with this end point?
What can I do with that end point?
Oh, this is weird functionality.
What can I do with that?
If you frame all of that towards your singular goal, it's going to make you think much more
creative and it's going to help you get to that goal much, much easier.
Yeah.
Totally agree with that.
One of the biggest bounties I've ever seen paid out in person was from a, uh, I don't
even know what they were called at that point.
Verizon media, Yahoo, Oath payout where they set a goal and they said, Hey, anyone who can
do arbitrary account takeover gets, you know, 50 K bonus or something ridiculous like that.
Right.
And somebody, you know, lo and behold, someone did it because they set up a goal.
So this is actually a tip for the, the program side as well.
If there are any, um, program managers listening to this pod, and I know there are, um, definitely,
you know, consider setting specific bonuses for things that are high value to you, like arbitrary
account takeover or, or like full read internal SSRF or something like that, because, uh, that
is a great way to motivate hackers in a very specific direction.
Grammarly is a great example of that.
Grammarly has a hundred K.
I think it's a hundred K.
If you can read a secret within a specific account or document or something, and that's
just in their policy page, you know, it's just been there.
So if you want to, you know, get that a hundred K, like frame everything you can to, to get that.
I've heard it's very difficult.
So we got to go after that.
We got to check that out.
I think that'd be cool.
Okay.
Um, the last one in the during hacking section is called impact lacked, impact lacked.
Um, and this is, this is sort of situation that you can fall into where you swing to the other
side and you get too curious or you get too focused, focused on just some weird functionality
that is like funky and odd, but doesn't necessarily have impact.
I see this all the time with new hunger hunters, like, oh, I found this like directory listing.
And there's look at all these directories in here.
And like, you know, oh, I can access all these files and what, this is amazing.
This is a phone.
No, that's, that's not a phone, um, because there's no impact to the customer.
So before you DM someone and you say, Hey, Justin, um, is this a phone?
You should ask yourself, why do I think this is a phone?
And you need to be able to answer that question.
What can I do that the company doesn't want me to be able to do?
And there could be an argument made that, you know, the company doesn't want you to be able to
see all of their directories in the directory listing, right?
To that, I would say that that doesn't meet the impact standards, but you need to outline
that sort of thought, that sort of mentality, um, uh, from the very beginning and make sure
that the thing you're going after actually has impact to the, to the company.
Yeah.
And on that, you gotta understand the threat model, right?
So like, if you are trying to explain this to a company, the best way to prove impact is to
explain it in a way that demonstrates impact.
Okay.
And so like, think about what does the company care about?
Is it user data?
Is it their data?
Is it intellectual property?
Whatever, right?
Like, but most of the time, that's not going to be a directory listing, unless that directory
listing has something in it that is impactful.
Right.
And so I think like, instead of just reporting a directory listing, look at the stuff in the
directory listing and see if you can find something more impactful.
Maybe then consider just reporting that as is, but I don't think like that would meet my criteria
either in terms of like, you know, uh, Oh, I'm going to report this and like get a sick bounty.
Like you're going to get like a hundred dollar bounty, you know?
Yeah, for sure.
Totally agree.
Yeah.
And nothing against a hundred dollar bounty, you know, a hundred dollar bounties.
A hundred dollars is a hundred dollars.
Yes.
And I, and I would, I would say, you know, if it meets the organization's threat model
and they've outlined that in the policy, then you should absolutely report that.
Yeah.
Take the hundred bucks, help the company and win, win, win.
But, um, also that's not going to be the case a large percentage of the time for something
like directory listings.
Cool.
Okay.
So after hacking.
Yeah.
After hacking.
Burnout.
No, you got to say the whole title.
You can't skip that.
I, I, I, after hacking the burnout turnout, there you go after hacking the burnout turnout.
Um, okay.
So you, you want to take this one?
Sure.
Yeah.
So I, I think you have, you're going to have a lot to say on this.
Um, I definitely have dealt with burnout so much.
Um, it, it definitely comes from different areas.
Sometimes it's that you've been doing a ton of hacking and you're not getting a ton of bounties.
Um, sometimes it's that you have been doing a ton of hacking and you haven't gotten a single bounty.
Um, sometimes it's that, you know, you, you've been, uh, looking at a target, you submitted a
bunch of cool things.
Turns out they were all internal dupes.
Um, there's a lot of different reasons that you can get burnout.
Um, and I think again, kind of like imposter syndrome, you, you, you have to remember this
is completely normal and it's not like you've done anything wrong to feel this way.
Um, burnout is like a very normal thing.
It's, it's probably more important to try and figure out what caused it and how you can
try and avoid it or ease that burnout in the future.
Yeah, I totally agree.
There has to be a mending process and a maintenance process.
Um, and so, you know, the mending piece is like, ah, all right, I'm burnt out.
How do I get out of this funk, right?
And the maintenance process is how do I not get burnt out in, in, in the first place?
And a lot of this, a lot of the, the things that for me with bug bounty that causes burnout
is this whole results for money impact, right?
Like if I, if I put all this effort in at my day job and something doesn't work out,
I still get a salary, you know, if I'm a salaried employee, but if I put all this results in and
or all this effort in and get no results out in bug bounty, nada, you know, and, and that's,
that's a, that's what happens from a material basis.
However, you got to understand that for every moment you're putting into not finding a bug
and getting a bounty, that's another minute that you will not have to spend until you find your
next, your next, you know, right?
So it's not actually, uh, useless.
It's not actually wasted time.
It's just a part of the process.
Yeah.
And you're learning a lot when that's happening.
Absolutely.
And you're learning a ton and that's, that's very, very tangible.
And this is one of the things that I, I've kind of talked to some of my friends that are,
that are starting, trying to like upstart some, some local businesses and trying to do sales.
Right.
Um, for every like X customers that you talk to and you get declined, like have something
that makes it feel worthwhile, like pay yourself an extra dollar or something like that.
If you have startup money or like, you know, say, all right, if I get 30 customers that say no
to me today, I'm going to just go get some Chick-fil-A or something like that.
Right.
You know, have some sort of metric that makes it still feel like, even though that person said,
no, your time wasn't wasted.
And the same thing happens here with, with bug bounty, you know, for every a hundred attack
vectors that you try, or for every 50 attack vectors that you try, whatever it is, you know,
do something that that's care, self-care so that you don't end up getting burnt out.
I was just thinking about like, uh, you're at your 29th rejection of the day.
You're, you're, you're, you got three calls left and you're like, please just say no.
I want the Chick-fil-A.
Yeah. The worst scenario is like, you have a goal for 10 calls, you know, and then you get the hot
tub or 10 yeses. Then you get the hot tub and then you get a call for 30, you know, 30 rejections.
And you got 29, nine and you should walk away. Cause you're done for the day. It's like,
shoot, you know, cool, man. No, that's funny.
So do you have like, um, like, what do you use for like personal tactics to like deal with this?
Cause I'm sure you, you deal with burnout all the time.
Yeah. Yeah, I do. And it's hard. Um, I think post live hacking event, I spend, uh, at least a week
of downtime and a lot of times, um, and we'll talk about this a little bit later. I've got some stuff
to catch up on, you know, after the live hacking event season, um, just some responsibilities that
have, uh, fallen to the side. But, um, as far as, you know, my long-term solutions for burnout,
I've actually suffered from burnout very little, um, in my, my three, three years. Yeah. Uh,
as a full-time bug bounty hunter, I, I, I attribute that largely to having a stable,
you know, marriage and personal life. And then also to prayer and to finding my identity in something
that is not bug bounty because I, I have the, the inclination to say like, man, if I'm not crushing
in bound in bug bounty, I suck. I am worthless, you know? And, and, you know, it's not something
I'm actively saying, but it's something that I'm feeling. Right. And so you really have to address
that first. You've got to put your, your, your hope, your, your identity, your self-worth in something
that is not your work, because especially in bug bounty, it's extremely dangerous. There is a whole
team of people on the other side of the computer whose job it is nonstop, you know, nine to five
every single day to make your job impossible. Right. That is, that's a lot of, that is a lot of
pushback. Right. And, um, and so, you know, keeping that in mind and, you know, finding your identity
elsewhere, really good. Also for me, I find it really helpful to get out in the sun, play some volleyball,
you know, have a decent workout routine, spend time with, with loved ones and family,
even though, you know, you're in the middle of a live hacking event or a really intense hacking
season. Um, and that will just allow you to move refreshed into the, the next time.
You're killing your, you're well-earned hot tub. Exactly. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. You get that first set
of goal, get a hot tub, then make that happen. Get in the hot tub. That's the solution. Everything
else doesn't matter. Once you're in the hot tub. Exactly. Awesome. At all costs, get the hot tub.
Awesome. Now, um, yeah. Do you have any comments on that or do you want to hop to the next one?
Um, no, I mean, I, I think I have a lot of the same type of, just like, try and separate yourself
away from it. Um, this is, again, we talked about this in, uh, in, in both the before hacking and
the during hacking, but bug bounty is not a guaranteed thing, right? Finding a bug, finding
a security vulnerability, especially a critical one, not guaranteed. And you have to remember that,
like, we are trying to like almost do the impossible here, right? We are, we are pushing
against talented security teams here to try and find the holes that they missed. And when you find
something that's awesome, but it's not guaranteed and you can't like beat yourself up for not, for like,
not finding a myth, like a mythical thing that may or may not exist. It's like nothing that you did
could have controlled that, right? And made it appear, right? It either exists or it doesn't. And
what really matters is whether or not you can identify it. And that's like completely separate
from like finding it. You know what I mean? Like, uh, I think like you can always like just take your
notes and stuff. You can always keep hunting, but, um, don't, don't beat yourself up for like
a good security team being good. You know, like that's a, that, that's kind of an unjustified
reason to beat yourself up.
Yeah, totally agree. Um, okay. So we've got two left in after hacking. Um, I know you got to bounce
here in a bit, Joel, so we'll try to move through them pretty quickly. Cause I want you to be around
for this report that I want to tell you about. Um, responsibility volatility is the next one.
Um, and essentially this is what I was talking about before where you get so pulled into hacking
that you've neglected other responsibilities, whether that be your relationship with your
significant other, whether it be your chores, you know, the dishes, the lawn, whatever. Um, it's very easy to get
focused and in the zone and then let everything else fall behind and it's not sustainable. And when
you do that and you let all the things fall behind and you let that get, and you don't, you know,
communicate well with your spouse or you don't hire someone to do your lawn or something like that,
then it becomes, um, that's a very easy way to get burnt out because you'll come out of the hacking
thing. And you'll have like a panic reaction and then you'll be stressed out trying to get all this
stuff done and get back up, caught up. And it's just an easy, really easy way to get yourself in a
rough situation. So don't become so fixated that, you know, you're not spending time with your loved
ones that you're not carrying with your responsibilities.
Yeah, for sure. It's a, it's important to treat bug bounty like a job if it is your full-time job,
right? Like don't, don't let those hours like abuse you. Just, you know, take it in a reasonable
pace. Don't like be working 15 hours a day, every single day, unless you feel like that's going to
really drive the results. And I still wouldn't recommend doing that at a lot for like a long
period of time. You know what I mean? Like that's, uh, that's a lot.
Yeah. Yeah. Well, one of the best things about being full-time bug bounty is you have a lot of
freedom, you know? And so make sure you're not squandering that because we're all, especially if
you're younger, you know, you're a time billionaire if you're not a money billionaire. Right. And so,
you know, you're trading your time for money and you, you know, you, you can trade your money for
time when you do stuff like, you know, pay people to do your lawn or whatever. Um, make sure you're not
squandering that asset of like, I can make good money and still have a lot of
freedom. Um, and I think that's something that I've learned recently and something that I'm
struggling to implement right now because I'm in the middle of a reno too. So I, my time is getting
really crunched, but once I get out of done with this, um, you know, rental property reno,
uh, I think I'll be a lot more enjoying the freedom that comes along with being full-time bug bounty.
Yeah, for sure. All right. And for the last one, payout phase out. I think this one is a lot more
relevant for like the full-time hunters, but, uh, really this is, you know, you,
you, you're waiting for a bounty, things start to slow down. You're like, I got the report in,
just wait and see when they pay it and, and see how I feel. But like that is a really easy trap to
fall into. Oh yeah. Yeah. And I think, I think, um, I think it's very tempting and, and there's,
there's two sides of this because one hand you kind of want to validate your threat model before you
spend a bunch of time on an organization that doesn't, that you think you understand their threat
model and you don't really understand. So that's one, you know, that's the positive side on waiting
for the bounty. But the negative side is like, you get into an app, you find some great bugs,
you write them up, you send them in, and then you just lose all context on that app. And that's not,
that's not great because a lot of the time, if there's a vulns in a specific area, there's probably
more vulns there. So go back, don't get too overexcited about the vuln that you found that you,
you miss other vulns. Um, and, and hit it again because, uh, there's likely other vulns there.
Yeah. Yeah. Super, super awesome advice. And, um, notes, you know, take notes. If you're, if you've
just like submitted a bug and you're like, this is going to be a sick payout and you're not sure what
to do next, check your notes, go look at the other stuff that you wrote down and you didn't feel like
you had fully investigated. That's a great opportunity to go look at some of that other
stuff now that you've kind of completed, you know, your, your train of thought and finished reporting
the bug, you know? Yeah. Um, Joel, I know you got to bounce here in a second. Feel free to,
to leave if you want, I can wrap things up, but I did want to, I did want to talk about this one
report. Um, I put it in the doc. It's, uh, uh, one that got disclosed this week on LinkedIn. Um,
and the title of it, entire database of emails exposed through URN injection. So when I saw this,
I was like, what the heck is URN injection? That is exactly what I just asked. And I, I,
I read this report and I was really impressed. Um, so from what I can tell here, um, this,
this individual found out that the system that LinkedIn is using, um, has this, this concept of a,
of a URN and, uh, I'll see if I can find the quote right here. It is possible to trigger a URN
resolution by assigning a URN value to a text field inside of the profile and using a decoration
expansion in, in a Voyager query. So essentially what he found out was that he could take this,
this URN and I think in the report, he puts it in the, um, in the website field. Um, and this URN,
just for those of you that are listening in the audio medium looks like URN colon, L I colon, uh,
the, the object that you're looking at, uh, FS underscore email address, colon, and then the actual
ID. Um, and so it's sort of like a structured ID, right? And so he takes that, he puts it in the
website field. And when the call, he makes this call to the API, to the Voyager API on LinkedIn,
um, that API will look at that URN that was there and say, okay, um, if this field is URN that I need
to resolve that URN. So it will go to the database, pull that value out and stick it in the included
field. Um, and I think he said that there was some sort of, um, uh, a parameter that allowed him to, uh,
tell it to resolve the included URNs. And then that gets included in this little,
I said included a lot of times in this little included section in the response. Um, this was
a type of vulnerability that I've, I've not seen before. And I have seen these URNs around. Um,
so this is definitely something to be aware of. Yeah. Super interesting. I think this URN stuff is
like, uh, maybe a Microsoft thing. I don't, I don't know why it took me until today to realize that
Microsoft owns LinkedIn. Yeah. Which is really interesting. I, I, I was just looking at the
Wikipedia. Apparently this happened in 2016, but I never, I don't ever remember. Like maybe I just
wasn't paying attention at the time, but just missed that. So I was like, why are these docs
on the Microsoft, on the Microsoft.com site? And, uh, yeah, that's why that's really, really,
really interesting. I wonder, uh, where else you could use this within Microsoft owned services.
Yeah, I totally, I totally agree. And I, I want to say there was even some mention of this in the, um,
in the writeup that Sam Curry did on the Starbucks, uh, bug that we found together leaking the 99 million
records on Starbucks. So, um, that could definitely be something to, to keep your eye on. And like we
always say, you know, these, these sort of things are the kind of things we'd love to cover the most
here, new techniques coming out, um, stuff that y'all ought to be aware of. So we'll link this, uh,
report in the, in the description, uh, definitely go check it out and shout out to ultra power.
The, uh, the guy who found this phone, um, uh, this is really, really good. Yeah. Super awesome.
Cool. You got anything else? All right, man. That's it for me. All righty. Catch you next week then.
Sweet. That's the pod.
Yo, thanks for watching this episode of critical thinking podcast. Hope you enjoyed it.
Um, if you wouldn't mind head over to YouTube and subscribe to our YouTube channel at youtube.com
slash at critical thinking podcast. Also drop a follow and subscribe on your podcast app of choice.
Uh, we will be soon launching a, uh, website at critical thinking podcast.io. Please head over
there as well. There'll be a newsletter signup where you can get notifications for each episodes,
as well as, uh, check out some transcriptions slash blog summaries of the episodes, which, um,
which might be of interest to you. Thanks. See you next week.